This is a first part of the year long course introducing you to all the major
ideas in physics,
starting from
Galileo and Newton,
right up to the big revolutions of the last century,
which was on relativity and quantum mechanics.
The target audience for this course is really very broad.
In fact,
uh,
have always been surprised at how broad the representation is.
So I don't know what your major is.
I don't know what you're going to do later.
So I picked the topics that all of us in physics find fascinating.
Uh,
some may or may not be useful,
but he just don't know.
Some of you are probably going to be doctors and you don't know why I'm going to
do a specialist activity or quantum mechanics,
but you don't know when it'll come in handy.
If you're a doctor and he got a patient who's running away from you or the speed
of light,
you'll know what to do.
Or if you're a pediatrician with a really small patient who will,
who will not sit still.
It's because the laws of quantum mechanics don't allow objects.
I have a definite cannot have a definite position and momentum.
So,
so these are all things you just don't know when they will come in handy.
And I teach them because uh,
these are the things that turned me on and got me going into physics and whether
or not you go into physics,
you should certainly learn about the biggest and most interesting revolutions
right up to present day physics.
All right,
so that's what the subject matter is going to be.
And I'm going to tell you a little bit about how the course is organized.
First thing is this year it's going to be taped.
You can see some people in the back of the cameras as part of an experimental
pilot program funded by the Hewlett Foundation.
And uh,
at some point they will decide what they will do with this lectures.
Most probably they'll post them somewhere so people for elsewhere can have the
benefit of uh,
what you have sitting in the yield classroom.
So I've been told that a firm,
not one,
we just ignore the camera and do business as usual and I think it's going to be
changed.
I tried to negotiate the laugh track so that the jokes don't work.
We can superimpose some laughter.
I was stolen.
No,
I just got to deal with it as it happens.
So it's going to be,
it's like one of the reality show us where things are going to be asked.
They are and hopefully after awhile we'll uh,
we'll learn to act and behave normally and not worry about his presence.
Then coming to the rest of the details of course,
by the way,
that are more details on the website that I posted that was given to me by the
university.
If you want to know more about what all this is about,
the course organization is fairly simple.
We are going to meet Monday and Wednesday in this room.
Uh,
1130 to 1245.
I will give you some problems to do on Wednesday and I'll post them on the
website.
You guys should get used to going into the classes website.
I'm really,
really dependent on that now.
I finally learned how to use it.
I will use that to post information.
Uh,
maybe once in a while we'll send email to the whole class.
If you want to get those emails,
you got to sign up for the course because I push a button and it goes to anybody
who's signed up there.
The homework will be given on Wednesday and it's due before class the following
Wednesday.
And I let me introduce you to our head,
ta Myra Daniel,
who's recently Myra rabbits,
right?
Uh,
she's really come a little.
Okay.
Samira is going to be the person who will see you after class and she will take
the problem sets that you have submitted before class and she'll give you the
greater ones from after class.
Okay.
That'll be sorted out.
It'd be up there.
So you should drop the homework before they come into class rather than
furiously working on it during class and the solutions will be posted the same
afternoon so that it's not much point in giving a homework that's late,
but once in a while you know,
you will come up with a reason that I just cannot argue with.
He got married getting a transplant,
whatever it is.
That's fine.
You got a transplant,
I want to see the old body part.
You got married,
I want to see your spouse.
If something happened to grandparents,
I'm counting and up to four I don't get suspicious,
go five,
six,
seven,
eight.
I will have to look into the family tree,
but you know,
look,
any reasonable excuse will be entertained and the relative importance given to
these different things is 20% for your homework,
30% for the midterm,
which will be sometime in October and 50% for the final.
That'll be the way that average,
but I have another
plan called the amnesty plan in which I also compared just your final grade,
what you're in the final exam and whichever is higher up the two is what I will
take to determine your overall course grade.
This is something I used to announce near the end,
but then some people felt that it's not fair not to know this from the
beginning.
So I'm telling you from the beginning,
but don't,
don't dream and think that somehow the final's going to be so much different
from your regular day to day performance.
But to give you some reason to live after the midterm.
So you feel like that is hope I can change everything overnight.
It does happen.
I put that in for a reason because sometimes some of you have not taken a
physics course and you don't know how to do well in physics and slowly you catch
on and by the time his final exam you crack the code,
you know how to do well as far as I'm concerned that it just fine if at the end
of the semester you take a three hour exam in a close environment than you
answered everything.
I don't care what you did in your homework or your midterm,
that's not relevant.
So that's how the grading will be done.
We have a virus group of TA's,
she is the head ta and she's the one you should write to whenever you have a
problem.
Then we also have,
uh,
two faculty members.
One is a postdoctoral fellow,
Mark Caprio mark.
Okay.
So he will have a discussion section on Tuesdays between one and two in Sloan
lab and uh,
Steve Fuller Neto.
I don't know if Steve is here or not.
They'll Steve,
our new assistant professor,
he will have a section on Tuesday night in Dunham Lab,
a room to 20 uh,
Tuesday night is the night when you people realize homework is due on Wednesday
so we know that.
So he will be there to comfort you and give you whatever help you need.
All right.
My own office hours.
I'm not determined yet.
I'll have to find out when it is.
Good for you.
I used to,
you know I live and work out of Sloan lab up on the hill and it was easy to have
office hours before or after class,
but now you have to make a special trip.
So just give me a little bit of time to find out maybe by soliciting email
responses from you.
What would be a good time for my office hours,
but for any procedural things like you know,
this problem set was not greater properly and so on.
There is no point emailing me because I'm going to send it to Myra anyway,
so directly deal with the powers that be
okay.
Finally,
I want to give you some tips on how to do well in this course and what attitude
you should have.
First advice is you should come to the lectures.
It's not self serving,
it's not the
so much for my benefit.
I think there is something useful about hearing the subject presenter once
orally.
Secondly,
the book you can see one of you had a book here,
uh,
in sport it's bought a 1100 pages and when I learned physics it was like 300
pages.
Now I look around this room,
I don't see anybody who's head is three times bigger than mine.
So I know that you cannot digest everything the books have.
So I have to take out what I think is really essential part and cover that in
the lecture.
So you come to class to find out what's in and what's not.
Then if you don't do that,
it's a danger.
You will learn something you don't have to and we don't want that.
Okay,
so that's where you come to class.
Second thing,
most important thing for doing well in physics is to do the homework.
The 20% given to the homework is not a real measure of how important it is.
Homework is when you really figure out how much you know and don't know.
If you watch me do the thing on the blackboard,
it looks very reasonable.
It looks like you can do it,
but only way we're going to find out is when you actually deal with the problem.
That's the only time you're going to find out,
so I asked you to do the problems as and when they're posted.
If you're posted on Wednesday is to cover the material for that week,
then you should attempted as quickly as possible because I'm going to assume
you've done.
The problem is when you come for the next few lectures and in doing the
homework,
it is perfectly okay to work in groups.
You don't have to do it for yourself.
That's not a physics has done.
I'm now writing a paper with two other people that are my experimental
colleagues who write papers with 400 other people,
maybe even a thousand other people when they do the big collider experiments in
Geneva and Fermi lab collaborations can run into a hundreds,
so it's perfectly okay to be a part of it collaboration,
but you got to make sure that you're pulling your weight.
You got to make sure that if you explain to others how to do this problem,
then somebody else contributed something else.
But you know what?
Everybody contributed in the end.
So the game is not just to somehow or other get the solution,
the problem set,
but to fully understand how it's done and the ts will be there to help you.
That's every day that's going to be a ta in the undergraduate lounge.
I would urge you to use that.
That's a beautiful new lounge that the provost's office allowed us to build for
physicists and chemists,
whoever happens to be in the building.
If you go there on the third floor of Sloan,
you may run into other people like you.
We're trying to work on problems you may run into upper class students.
Students are more advanced,
you run into your ta.
So that's a good climate that our coffee machines and that allowing sofas and
everything else,
uh,
that are computers or printers.
So it's a good lounge.
And I think if you go there one day a week to do your problem sets or more
often,
that's a good meeting place.
I recommend that.
Final piece of advice,
this is very important.
So please pay attention to this,
which is,
I asked you not to talk to your neighbors during lecture.
Now this looks like a very innocuous thing,
but you will find out.
It's the only thing that really gets my backup.
Most of the time.
I don't really care.
I'm very liberal,
but this disturbs me because I am looking at you.
I'm trying to see from your reaction how much of your,
of my lecture you're following.
And then it's very distracting when people are talking.
So please don't do that.
Uh,
if you talk,
I'm going to assume you're talking about me.
If you laugh,
I'm going to assume you're laughing at me.
Let's make that.
That's not really what I think,
but that's how disturbing it is when people talk and very nice students who do
not realize this often disrupt my straight,
my line of thinking.
So I asked you to keep that to a minimum.
Once in a while you'll have to talk to your neighbor and say,
can you please pass me my pacemaker that fell down?
That's fine.
Then you go back to your business,
but don't,
don't do too much of that.
Finally that this is ancient issue about sleeping in the class.
Now my view is it's just fine.
Okay,
I know you guys need the rest.
And interestingly,
the best sleeper cell in the first couple of rows,
I haven't met you guys at person.
I have found some people really have to come to the first or second row because
they claimed that if they don't hear me,
they cannot really go to sleep.
That was true in Sloan,
but I think Lewis has got very good at acoustics so you can stretch out in the
back.
But my only,
uh,
only criteria is if you talk in your sleep.
Now that's not a lot of talking us.
Next,
if you're going to sleep,
I ask you to sit between two non slippers because sometimes what happens the
whole row will topple over.
We don't want the domino effect.
Now it's going to be a captured on tape and I'm just going to be really bad for
my reputation.
So spread yourself for yourself around the other people.
Alright,
so that's it.
In terms of class,
you know,
largest sticks and everything.
I'm going to start going into the physics proper.
I will try to finish everything on time,
but sometimes I move in the middle of a sentence or in the middle of the day
innovation and they have to go over by a couple of minutes.
There was no need to shuffle your feet and move stuff around.
I know what time it is.
I also want to get out like you guys,
but let me finish something.
Other days I may finish a few minutes before time.
That's because the ideas of physics don't fall into a 75 minute segments and
sometimes they spill over a little bit.
Also,
I'm used to teaching this course three times a week and now it's suddenly twice
a week.
And so things that fell into a nice 50 minutes units are now being snipped up
different ways.
So it's pretty difficult.
So even for me,
some of it will be new and the timing may not be just right.
Okay.
Anybody have any,
I should tell you first of all that in this class,
the taping is not going to affect you because the camera's going to be behind
your head.
I mentioned to you in the website that this is not the big opportunity.
You've been looking for a to be a star.
Uh,
only the back of it,
it'll be seen.
I've,
in some cases,
the back of the head could be more expressive than the front,
in which case this is your opportunity to get,
I wish you luck,
but otherwise just don't worry about it because you will be only heard,
you may not even be heard.
Uh,
so I've been asked that if a question is not very clear,
I should repeat it so that people listening to the later we'll know what the
question was,
but I would ask you,
uh,
let me make one thing very clear that is I'm not in favor of you are talking to
each other because of distracting your stopping me anytime.
It's just fine.
All welcome that because I've seen the subject for gardeners how many years.
The only thing that makes it different from me is the questions that you people
have.
So you can stop me anytime and you should not feel somehow you're stopping the
progress of the class.
That is no fixed syllabus.
We can move things around and just part him.
What exciting for me to answer your questions then to have a monologue.
So don't,
don't worry about that.
So stop me anytime you don't fall or something and don't assume that you're not
falling something because there's something wrong with your level of
comprehension.
Quite often you guys come up with questions that never crossed my mind.
It's a very interesting and things we may repeat in year after year after year
because they sound so reasonable,
suddenly sound unreasonable when some of you point out some aspect of it that
you didn't follow.
So it could be very interesting for all of us to have issues discussed in class
and quite often some precedence are very common and your classmates will be
grateful to you that you brought it up.
Otherwise,
do you know you get 10 tiers,
get 10 emails all with the same question.
Okay.
So I'm going to start now.
Anybody have any uh,
questions about class?
The format,
the midterm exams?
All right.
Yes.
There's going to be two hours to be announced.
Oh,
you mean,
uh,
my office hours?
Nope.
No,
the discussion sections are Tuesday afternoon from one to two and Tuesday night
from eight to 10.
And the,
the website has got all the details on when and where.
Yes.
Yeah.
That are many,
many lab times.
And uh,
you have to go to the website for the lab.
And by the way,
that reminds me,
I got here lots of flyers given to me by the director of the laboratories,
which we'll tell you which lab is the right lab for you and they're offered many
times a week.
Yes,
I'm as far as goes into material just from your class.
How important is taking the lab and currently with this class?
I think it's a good idea to take the lab because it,
particularly in this particular class,
because I don't have any demonstrations,
they're all in the other building.
So this will remind you that physics is after all an experimental science and
you will be able to see where all the laws of physics come from.
So if you're going to take it,
you should take it at the same time.
Yes.
Yeah.
Ah,
very good.
This is a calculus based class and expect everyone to know at least the
rudiments of differential calculus.
What's the function,
what the data deliver,
do what the secondary with the how to take derivatives,
elementary functions,
how to do elementary integrals.
Sometime later I will deal with functions are more than one variable,
which I will briefly introduce you because that is may not be prerequisite,
but certainly something you will learn and you may use on and off.
But,
uh,
there are different ways of doing physics minus to demonstrate over and over how
little mathematics you need to get the job done.
There are others who like to show you how much mathematics you could somehow
insinuate into the process.
Okay.
There are different ways of playing the game and some of his find great pride in
finding the most simple way to understand something that certainly my trademark,
that's how I do my research also.
So if you feel there's not enough Matthews,
I guarantee you that I certainly know enough.
Uh,
eventually the snow,
the whole class.
But that's another point.
I will use it in moderation and used it to use it to the best effect possible
rather than use it because it is there.
Okay.
So,
I don't know your mathematical background,
but the textbook has an appendix because reasonable measure of how much math you
should know,
you got to know you or trigonometry,
you got to know what's the sign and what's the cost sign.
Uh,
you cannot say,
I will look it up.
Your birthday and social security number is what you look up trigonometry,
functions,
you know,
all the time.
Okay.
I will assume you do.
All right.
And of course [inaudible] metric identities,
you know from high school pages and pages of them.
So no one expects you to know all those identities,
but there are a few popular ones we will use.
All right.
Uh,
anything else?
Yes,
that's maybe a bit really.
Yeah.
Midterm will be sometime around 20th of October.
I have to find out exactly the right time.
We have 24 lectures for this class and the first 12 roughly will be part of the
midterm.
But after the 12th lecture,
I may wait a week so that you had time to do the problems and get the solutions.
Then I will give you the midterm.
Yes.
Which one?
Yeah.
This tells you in detail this flyer answers exactly that.
Okay.
There's one more question.
Somebody.
Yes.
I'm a few people I've talked
to have recommended that will start taking the labs second semester instead of
first.
Would that be advisable or should we take photos?
I don't have a strong view.
I think you should take the lab sometime but uh,
I don't know how many semesters semesters of it you have to take.
But I would say the advice of your predecessors is very important.
It did tell you this is what works.
That's better than what somebody like me can tell you.
Honestly.
You should talk to Steven Irons who is the director of the labs.
He has seen every possible situation he would give you good advice.
Let's stop now.
Okay,
so we are going to be studying the beginning watch called Newtonian mechanics.
It's pretty remarkable that the whole edifice was set up by just one person,
Newton and he set us on the road to understanding all the natural phenomena till
the year 1800 and something when Maxwell invented the laws of electromagnetism
and wrote down the famous Maxwell equation.
But except for electromagnetism,
the basics of mechanics,
which is the moist enough billiard balls and trucks and marbles and whatnot was
set up by Newton.
So that's what we're going to focus on.
And you will find out that the laws of physics for this entire semester
certainly can get it done on one of those blackboards that even half of those
blackboards.
And the purpose of this course is to show you over and over and over again that
starting with those one or two laws,
you can deduce everything and I would encourage you to think the same way.
In fact,
I would encourage you to think the way physicists do,
even if you don't plan to be a physicist,
because that's the easiest way to do the subject and that is to follow the
reasoning behind everything I give you.
And my purpose will be not to say something as a postulate,
but to show you where everything comes from and is best for you if you try to
follow the logic that way you don't have to store do many things in your head.
In the early days when there were four or five formulas.
You can memorize all of that and you can try it one of them until something
works.
But after a couple of weeks you will have a hundred formulas and you cannot
remember is all of them.
You cannot resolve to trial and error.
So you have to know the logic,
the logical ways,
not just the way the physicist do it.
It's the easier way to do it.
If that is another way that you work for non physicists,
I won't hesitate to teach it to you that way.
That turns out to be the best way to try to follow the logic of everything.
Okay,
so Newtonian mechanics is that we're where's topic?
So Newtonian mechanics has two
or all of physics can consists of two is a two part program plan.
Every time is to predict the future given the present.
That's what we always do.
When we do that right,
we are satisfied.
The question is what do you mean by predict the future?
What do you mean by the future?
What do you mean by the present?
By present,
we mean we'll pick some part of the universe we want to study
and we will ask what information do I need to know about that system at the
initial time,
like right now in order to be able to predict the future.
So for example,
if you were trying to study the motion of some object,
okay,
here's one example here.
See that's an example of Newtonian mechanics.
I'll give you one more demonstration.
Let's see,
we can get this one.
That's a good example.
So that was Newtonian mechanics at work because what did I do is I released a
piece of candy through it from my hand and the initial condition had to do with
where do they release it and with what?
Velocity.
That's what he sees with his eyes.
Then that's all you really need to know.
Then he knows it's going to go up,
it's going to curve follow some kind of Parabola.
Then his hands go there to receive it.
That is verification of a prediction.
It's prediction was the candy's going to land here and he put his hand there.
He also knew where the candy is going to land,
but he couldn't get his hand there in time.
But we can always make predictions.
But this is a good example of what you need to know.
What is it he had to know about this object that was thrown?
I claim is the initial location of the object,
the initial velocity,
the fact that it was blue or red,
not relevant.
And if I threw a girl at him,
it doesn't matter.
Uh,
you know what the color of the good realize what mode it is in.
these are things we don't deal with in physics or if there is a tall building
standard physics problem and object falls off,
a tall building object could be a person.
So we don't ask,
why is this guy ending it all today?
That's not,
we don't know.
And we cannot deal with that.
So we don't answer that everything.
We just want to know when it's going to hit the pavement
and with what speed.
So we asked very limited questions,
which is why we brag about how accurately we can predict the future.
So we only ask limited goals and we already successful and satisfying them.
So we had basically dealing with inanimate objects.
So the project of Newtonian mechanics or predicting the future given the present
has got two parts and I'll one is called kinematics and the other is called
dynamics.
So kinematics is a complete description of the present.
It is the list of what you have to know about the system right now.
But example,
if you're talking about the chocolate,
but throw the chalk,
you will have to know where it is and how fast it's moving.
The dynamics doesn't dynamics then tells you
why the object goes up,
why the object goes down,
why is it pulled down and so on.
That's dynamics.
The reason it comes down as gravity's pulling it in Kinematics,
you don't ask the reason behind anything.
You simply want to describe things,
the where they are and then dynamics tells you how they change and why they
changed.
So I'm going to illustrate the idea of kinematics by taking the simplest
possible example.
That's going to be the way I'm going to do everything in this course.
I'm going to start with the simplest example and slowly add on and wisdoms and
make it more and more complicated.
So
some of you might say,
well I've seen this before,
so maybe that is nothing new here that may well be,
I don't know how much you've seen,
but quite often the way you learn physics,
uh,
earlier on in high school is probably different from the way professional
physicists think about it,
the sense of values we have.
But things that we get excited about a different and the problems may be more
difficult.
But I want to start in every example in every situation that explained to you
the simplest example and slowly add on things.
So what we are going to study now is a non living object and we're going to pick
it to be a mathematical point.
So the object is a mathematical point.
It has no size.
If you rotated,
you won't know.
It's not like a potato take a potato,
you turn it around,
it looks different.
So it's not enough to say the potato is here,
you got to see which way the nose is pointing and so on.
So we don't want to deal with that.
Now that comes later when we study what are called rigid bodies.
Right now we want to study an entity which has no spatial extent,
so it just a doc and the doc can move around all over space.
So we're going to simplify that too.
We are going to take an entity that lives along the x axis.
It moves along the line so you can imagine a bead with the wire going through it
and the beat can only slide back and forth.
So this is about the simplest thing.
I cannot reduce the number of dimensions.
One is the lowest dimension.
I cannot make the objects simpler than being just a mathematical point.
Then you've got to say,
what do I have to know about this object at the initial time?
What constitutes the present or what constitutes maximal information about the
present?
But what we do is we pick an origin college zero.
We put some markers there to measure distance and we say this guy is sitting at
one two,
three,
four,
five is sitting at x equal to five.
Now,
of course we got have units and the units for lengths are going to be meters.
The units for time will be second
at time,
will be measured in seconds.
Then we'll come to other units right now in kinematics.
This is all you need.
Now there are some tricky problems in the book.
Sometimes they give you the speed in miles per hour,
kilometers per year,
pounds per square foot,
whatever it is you gotta learn to transform them.
That I won't do that.
I think that's pretty elementary stuff.
But uh,
sometimes I may not rate the units,
but I weren't the right to do that.
And you guys haven't.
So you still have to keep track of your units.
Everything's gotta be in the right units.
If you don't have the units,
then if you say the answer is 19,
then we don't know what it means.
Okay,
so here's an object or a given instant.
It's got a location.
So what we would like to do is to describe what the object does.
We're drawing a graph of time versus space.
And the graph could be something like this.
You got to learn how to read this graph.
I'm assuming everyone was how to read it.
This doesn't mean the object is bobbing up and down.
I hope you realize that even though the graph is going up and down,
the object is moving from left to right.
So for example,
when it does,
this is crossed the origin and is going to the left of the origin.
Now which the left of the origin,
it turns around,
they start coming to the origin and going to the right.
That is x versus t.
So the language of calculus x is a function of time
and this is a particular function.
This function doesn't have a name are other functions which have a name.
For example,
this is x equals t x equal the t square.
You're can have x equal the scientists co-signed t and live.
These are some functions have a named.
Some functions don't have a name.
What a product will tries to do generally is some crazy thing which doesn't have
a name,
but it's a function except tea.
So you should know when you look at a graph like this,
water is doing.
So the two most elementary ideas you learn or what is the
average velocity of an object
that's been ordered by the symbol,
the bar.
So the average is found by taking two instance in time,
say t one and later t two
and you find out where it was a t to wellness where this was a t one and divide
by the time.
So the average velocity may not tell you the whole story.
For example,
if you started here and he did all this and you came back here,
the cabinet to the lost,
it would be zero because you start and end at the same value of x.
You get something zero divided by time,
it would still be zero.
So you cannot tell from the average everything that happened because of the way
to get the same zero is to just not move at all.
So the average is what it is.
It's an average.
It does not give you enough detail.
So it's useful to have.
The of philosophy is useful to have the average acceleration which you can find
by taking a similar differences of velocities,
but before they even do that,
I wanted to find for you an important concept which is the velocity at a given
time.
So this is the central idea of calculus,
right?
I'm hoping that if you learned your calculus,
you learned about derivatives and so on by looking at experts as tea.
So I will remind you again,
this is an odd of course in calculus I don't have to do with any detail.
I will dry the famous picture of some particle moving and it's here at time t at
some value of x
a little later,
which is time t plus Delta t the Delta t is going to stand always for a small
finite interval of time,
infinite decimal interval of time,
not yet zero.
So during that time the particles gone from here to there.
That is x plus delta x and the average velocity in that interval is delta x.
They waited with Delta t graphically.
This guy is delta x and this guy is Delta t and Delta x over delta.
T is the ratio.
So in Calculus,
what do you want to do is to get the notion of the velocity.
Right now we all have an intuitive notion of velocity.
Right now when you're driving in your car,
that's the needle and the needle says 60.
That's the velocity at this incident.
It's very interesting because the velocity seems to require two different times
to define it.
The initial time in the final time.
And yet you want to talk about the velocity right now that is the whole triumph
of countless.
This know that by looking at the position now the position slightly later,
take the ratio and bringing later as close as possible.
Right now we define a quantity that we can say is the velocity at this incident.
So VFT
is the limit.
Delta t goes to zero.
If a bell tags over Delta t and we use the symbol
dx dy,
deeper velocity.
So technically if you ask what is the velocity is stand for,
it stands for,
uh,
let me drop general situation.
If a particle goes from here to here,
Delta x over Delta t,
I don't know how well you can see it in this figure.
Here is the slope of a straight line connecting these two points and as the
points come closer and closer,
straight line will become tangent to the curve.
The velocity at any part of the curve is kinder to the curb at that point is
tangent of the data.
This angle is data.
Then delta x over Delta,
t by Technomic tree stand data.
Okay.
Once you can take one day out of it too,
you can take any number of elevators and the of of of the velocity
is called the acceleration and we write it as the second bit of it.
The position position.
I'm hoping you guys are comfortable with the notion of taking one or two or a
number of databases.
Interestingly,
the only,
the first two directors have a name.
First one is if I lost the second one is acceleration.
The third data to unfortunately was never given a name and I don't know why.
I think the main reason is that there are no equations that involve the third
delivered to explicitly f equals m a the a is this fella here and nothing else
is given an independent name.
Of course you can take a function and did it take,
did have it.
There's any number of times.
So you're supposed to know.
But example,
if x of t is due to the end,
you're supposed to know DXDT end to the t with n minus one.
Then he supposed to know I did of it is so simple functions like science and
coastlines.
So if you don't know that,
then of course you have to work harder than other people,
you know that uh,
that may be enough for quite some time.
Okay.
So what I've said so far is a particle moving in time from point to point can be
represented by a graph x versus t or any point on the graph.
You can take the date of it too,
which will be tangent to the curve on each point.
And there's new medical value will be what you can call the instantaneous
velocity at that point.
And you can take the deliver to the derivative and call it the acceleration,
so we are going to specialize to a bitty limited class of problems in the rest
of this class.
The limit of class of problems is one in the acceleration
is just a constant,
no,
that is not the most general thing but I am sure you guys have some idea why we
are interested in that so anybody know why that's such a big so much time is
spent on that.
Yes.
Pardon me.
Right.
The most famous example is that when things fall near the surface of the earth,
they all have the same acceleration and the acceleration that's most common is
called g and this 9.8 meters per second square,
so that's a very typical problem and you falling in the surface of the earth,
you are describing a problem,
constant acceleration.
That's the way this is a lot of emphasis on sharpening your deep by doing this
class of problems.
The question we are going to ask is the following.
If I tell you that the particle is a constant acceleration,
a,
can you tell me what the position x is?
Okay.
Normally I will give you a function and tell you to take any number of
databases.
That's very easy.
This is the backwards problem.
You,
you're only given the particulates acceleration a and you want to ask to find
out what is x.
In other words,
your job is to guess a function secondary to his aid
and this is called integration,
which the opposite of differentiation and integration is just guessing.
Integration is not an algorithmic process like different stations.
If I give you a function,
you know how to take the date of it.
It changed the independent variable,
find the change in the function,
take the ratio and that's the bit of it.
Then the opposite is being asked here I tell you something about the second bit
of it to have a function and ask you what is the function.
The way we do that is we guess and the guessing has been going on for 300 years.
So we sort of know how to guess.
So let me think aloud and ask how I will guess in this problem.
I would say,
okay,
this guy wants me to find a function which reduces to the number a,
when I take two databases,
and I don't sound bad here,
uh,
this result we'd say is that when I take a derivative,
I lose the power of t
in the end.
I don't want any powers of tea very clear.
I got to start with function that looks like t square.
This weight.
When I take two derivatives,
there'll be no t left.
But unfortunately we know this is not the right answer because if it take the
first little bit of,
I get to t,
I take the second date of it too.
I get to what I wanted to get a and not to.
Then it's very clear.
The way you find Pat's it up is you multiply it by this constant,
and I'll be at onset.
This function will have the right secondary of it.
So there's certainly describes a particle whose acceleration is a but a is not
dependent on time.
But the question is,
is this the most general answer odyssey?
Just one answer,
and I think you all know that this is not the most gender land,
city.
There's one answer,
but I can add to this some number like 96
they'll still have the property that if you take two derivatives,
you're going to get the same acceleration,
so 96 now we said typical constants.
I'm going to give the name,
see that constantly
everyone was from calculus that if you'd it to find a function about which you
know only the date of it have.
You can always add a constant to one person answer without changing anything,
but I think he had,
you know,
you can do more,
right?
You can add something else to the answer without invalidating it and that is
anything with one power of t in it
because if you'd take one database,
it'll survive,
but if you take two derivatives it it'll get wiped out.
No,
it's not obvious,
but it is true that you cannot add to this anymore.
Basic idea in solving these equations in integrating is you find one answer,
so they'd been taken.
A bit of it is the function does what they're supposed to do,
but then having phone one answer,
you can add to it.
Anything that gets killed by the act of taking databases,
you're taking only one database.
We can add a constant.
If you're taking to that evidence,
you can add a constant and something linear.
In t if you knew only the third database of the function,
you can have something quadratic and t without changing the outcome.
So this is the most general
position for a particle of constant acceleration.
Hey,
oh,
you must remember that this describes the particle going side to side.
I can also describe a particle going up and down.
If I do that,
I would s I would like to call that coordinate why.
Then I will write the same thing.
You've got to realize that in Calculus,
the symbols that you call x and y are completely arbitrary.
If you know what the second database,
why I like to be a,
then the answer looks like this.
If you knew the second [inaudible] the answer looks like that.
No.
We have asked,
uh,
what are these numbers B and c.
So let me go back now to this expression,
x of t equals [inaudible] squared over two
plus c.
Let's beat t.
Okay?
It is true mathematically you can add two numbers,
but you've got to ask yourself,
what am I doing as a physicist when I add these two numbers,
what am I supposed to do with a and B?
I mean with this BMC,
what balance should I pick?
The answer is that simply knowing the particle has that acceleration.
It's not enough to tell you where the particle will be.
For example,
let's take the case where the particle is falling under gravity.
Then you guys know,
you just told me acceleration is minus 9.8 but Geez,
minus 9.8 we call it minus because it's accelerating down and upper stake and to
be the positive direction in that case,
y of t
will be minus one half Gd Square.
Let's see,
let's bt.
So the point is every object falling under gravity is given by the same formula.
But there are many,
many objects that can have many histories all falling under gravity and what's
different from one object.
The other object is when was the drop from what height and with what initial
speed
that that's what these numbers are going to tell us and we can verify that as
follows.
If you want to know what the number is,
c is you say,
let's put time t equals to zero.
In fact,
let me go back to this equation here for put time t equals zero x six zero it
doesn't have this term,
it doesn't have this term and it is c.
So I realized that the constancy is the initial location of the object and it's
very common to denote that by x not.
Yeah,
so the meaning of the constant is where was the object of the initial time.
It could've been anywhere simply knowing the acceleration.
It's not enough to tell you where it was.
That initial time you get to pick where it was at the initial time.
Then to find the meaning of B.
We take one day too with this DXDT that's velocity as a function of time,
and if you took the derivative of this guy,
you'll find this 80 plus B.
That's the velocity of the object.
Then you can then understand that the UB zero is what bees,
which we write as vizio.
Okay,
so the final answer is that x of t
looks like X.
Nod plus B,
not the,
there's one half 80 square.
Okay.
Okay,
so what I'm saying here is we are specializing to limited class of motion where
the particle has a definite acceleration.
A then in every situation where the body has an acceleration,
a,
the location has to have this form where this number is where it was initially.
This was the initial velocity of the object.
So when I threw that thing up and you caught it,
what you were doing mentally was immediately figuring out where it started and
at what speed.
That was your initial data then in your mind,
without realizing it,
you found the trajectory at all.
Fuse at times?
No.
That is one other celebrate formula that goes with this.
I'm going to find that.
Then we will,
I'll give you an example.
No,
I'm fully aware that,
uh,
this is not the flashiest example in physics,
but I'm not worried about that right now.
You will have,
you'll see enough things that will confound you.
But right now I want to demonstrate a simple paradigm of what it means to nor
the present and what it means to say this is what the future behavior will be.
And we want to do that in the simplest context.
Then we can make the example more than more complicated,
but the phenomenon will be the same.
So what we have found out so far,
uh,
I'm purposely going from x to y because I want you to know that the unknown
variable can be called an exit can be called a y.
It doesn't matter
as long as the second day debate of is it,
that's the answer.
No,
that's the second Formula One.
Did I from this?
You guys probably know that too from your days at the daycare,
but I wanted,
did I have that formula?
And put it up.
Then we will see how to use them.
Second formula tries to relate the final velocity at some time.
T two the initial velocity and the distance traveled with no difference at a
time.
So the trick is to eliminate time from this equation.
So let's see how we can eliminate time.
You know that if you took a deliver to with this will find the EFT is v zero
less AA fee.
What that means is if you know the the last year they've given time and you know
the initial velocity,
you know what time it is,
the time in fact this v Minus v zero over day.
If I don't show you any arguments for be,
it means to be at time t and the subscript zero means we have zero.
So what this says is you can measure time by having your own clock.
The clock tells you what time it is,
but you can also say what time it is by seeing how fast the particle is moving.
Because you know it started with some speed,
it gaining speed or some rate a.
So if the speed was so and so now that the time had to be this,
the time can be indirectly inferred from these quantities.
Then you'd take that here and you put it here,
able to see at time t you put this expression,
so what will you get will get an expression in which that is no,
he has been banished in favor of this.
I'm not going to waste your time by asking what happens if you put it there.
I will just tell you what happens.
What happens is you will find that we square is equal to v Zero Square plus two
times x minus x zero.
Yeah.
How many people have seen this thing before?
Okay,
that's a lot.
Look,
I know you've seen this
at the moment.
I have to go through some of the more standard material before we go to the more
nonstandard material.
If this part's very easy for you,
there's not much I can do right now,
so let me draw a box.
Just drawing a box.
Do you guys means important?
These are the two important things
I claim.
Now remember,
I want you to understand one thing.
How much of this should you memorize supports?
You've never seen this in high school?
How much are you supposed to memorize?
I would say keep that to a minimum because what the first formula tells you,
it should be so intuitive that you don't have to cram this.
We're talking about particles of constant acceleration.
That means when I take two derivatives,
I want to get a,
then you should know enough calculus.
You know,
it has to be something like 80 square and a half comes from taking to
derivatives.
The other two,
you know or stuff you can add and you know what,
while you're adding those things,
because the particle has a headstart is going to get an initial position even at
equal to zero and it has an initial velocity.
So even without any acceleration,
it'll be moving from.
Why not two?
Why not?
Plus VT?
The acceleration gives you an extra stuff,
a quadratic and time.
Once you get God that one day that will give you the velocity than in a crunch.
You can eliminate tea and put it into this formula.
But most people end up memorizing these two because you use it so many times,
eventually sticks in you.
But you shouldn't try to memorize everything.
So we are now going to do one standard problem where we will convince ourselves
we can do,
we can apply these formulas and predict the future given the present.
So the problem I want to do,
there are many things you could do but I just picked one.
This is the one with the round numbers so I can do it without a calculator.
So here's a problem that is this building
and it's going to be 15 meters high
and I'm going to throw something and it's going to go up and come down.
But something I throw up as an initial speed of 10 meters per second.
So we have to ask now,
now that my claim is,
you can ask me any question you want about this party and I can answer.
You can ask me where did it be nine seconds from now,
eight seconds from now.
How fast will it be moving?
I can answer anything at all,
but what I needed to do it to do this problem was to find these two unknowns.
So you got to get used to the notion of what will be given in general and what
is tailor made to the occasion.
So we know in this example,
the initial height should be 15 meters in the initial velocity should be 10 and
for acceleration I'm going to use minus g and to keep life simple,
I am going to call it minus 10 as you know,
the correct answers 9.8 but we don't want to use the calculator now so we'll
call it my understand.
Consequently for this object,
the position why or any time t is known to be 15 plus 20 minus five t square,
okay?
That is the full story of this object.
Of course,
you've got to be little careful when you use it.
Uh,
for example,
let's put t equal to 10,000 years.
What are we going to get if a particular 10,000 years or 10,000 seconds you're
going to find why is some huge negative number now set right there.
What's wrong with that reasoning.
So you cannot use a formula once it hits the ground because once it hits the
ground,
the fundamental premise that a was a constant of minus 9.8 or minus 10 is wrong.
So that's another thing to remember.
Once you get a formula,
you got to always remember the terms under which the formula was derived.
If you blindly use it beyond the validated you will get results with.
Don't make any sense.
Conversely,
if you get an answer and it doesn't seem to make sense,
then you got to go back and ask,
am I violating some of the assumptions?
And here you will find the assumption that the particle have that acceleration
is true as long as it's freely falling under gravity but not when you hit the
ground.
My,
if you dug a hole here
till there,
then of course it may work til that happens.
Okay,
but you have,
you got an every time when you,
this is so obvious in this problem,
but when you see more complicated formula,
you may not know all the assumptions that went into derivation and quite often
you'll be using it when you shouldn't or exceed this you agree is a complete
solution to this miniature tiny Mickey mouse problem.
You to give me the time and I'll tell you where it is if you want and how fast
it's moving at a given time.
If you want another philosophy,
I just take the deliver to of this answer,
which just 10 minus 10 t
yeah,
so let me pick a couple of trivial questions.
One,
can I ask,
one can ask the following question,
how high does it go?
How high will it rise?
To what height will it rise so we know it's going to go up and turn it around
and come down.
We're trying to see how high that is.
So that is a tricky problem to begin with because if you take this formula here,
it tells you why if you not tea.
But now we are not saying that.
We don't know at the time
and we don't know how high it's rising,
so you're can ask,
how am I supposed to deal with this problem?
Then you put something else that you know in your mind,
which is that the highest point is the point.
When is neither going up nor coming down.
If it's going up,
that's not the highest point.
There's coming down.
That's not the highest point,
so at the highest point it cannot go up and it cannot go down.
That's the point where velocity is zero.
If you do that,
let's call the particular time please star.
Then 10 t star minus 10 is equal to zero.
Our t start is one second,
so we know that it'll go up for one second.
Then it'll turn it around and come back.
Now we had duck because now you can ask how high does it go?
Then you go back to your why of one and way of one is 15 plus 10 minus five
which is what?
20 meters.
By the way,
you will find that I make quite a lot of mistakes on the blackboard.
You're going to find out,
you know one of these years when you start teaching that when you get really
close to blackboard or you just cannot think,
that's definitely an inverse correlation between your level of thinking and
approximately to the blackboard.
So if you find me making mistake,
you got to stop it.
Why do you stop me for two reasons.
First of all,
I am very pleased when this happens because I'm pretty confident that I can do
this under duress,
but I may not do it right every time,
but if my students can catch me making mistake,
it means they are following it and they're not hesitating to tell me.
Secondly,
as we go into the more advanced part of the course,
we'll take a result from this part of the blackboard,
stick it into the second part and keep manipulating.
If I screwed up in the beginning and you guys keep quiet,
we'll have to do the whole thing again.
I would,
I would ask you when you follow this thing,
do it actively try to be one step ahead of me.
For example,
if I'm stuck by lightening,
can you do anything?
Can you guess what I'm going to say next?
You have any idea where this is going?
You shouldn't have a clue.
If I die and you stop,
that's not a good sign.
Okay?
You got to keep going a little further because you should follow the logic.
So for example,
you know I'm going to calculate next when it hits the ground,
you should have some idea how I'll do it because this is not a spectator sport.
If you just watch me,
you're going to learn nothing.
It's like watching the US Open and thinking you are some kind of player you will
have to do,
you will have to shed the tears and you got to bang your head on the wall and go
through your own private struggle.
I cannot do that for you.
I cannot even make it look hard because I've memorized this problem from
childhood.
So there is no way I can make this look difficult.
Okay,
that's your job.
All right,
so we know this point at one second is 20 meters.
So let's just ask one other question.
We'll start.
One other question may be when does it hit the ground and at what speed?
At typical physics question.
So when does it hit the ground?
Well,
I think,
uh,
you must know now how to formulate that question.
When does it hit the ground is when is y equals zero.
By the way,
I didn't tell you this but I think you knew that I pick my origin to be here and
measured why positively to be upwards.
And I call that 15 meters.
You can call that your origin.
If you call that your origin,
your y zero will be zero,
but ground will be called minus 15.
So in the end the physics is the same,
but the numbers describing it can be different,
but you have to interpret the data differently.
But the standard,
uh,
origin for everybody is the foot of the building.
You can pick your origin here,
some crazy spot,
it doesn't matter,
but some origins are more equal than others because there are some natural
landmark they're here for,
to the building is what I call the origin.
So in that notation,
I want to ask when is y equal to zero
for ask when y is equal to zero.
Then I say zero is 15 plus 20 minus five t square or I canceling the five
everywhere and changing the sign here I get teased.
Square minus two t minus three equals zero that's when it hits ground.
So let's find out what the time is.
So t is then
two plus or minus four plus 12 over two which is two plus or minus four over two
which is minus one or three.
Okay,
so you get two answers when it hits the ground.
So it's clear that we should pick three,
but you can ask why is it giving me a second solution?
Anybody have an idea why it's yes.
[inaudible]
that's correct.
So to answer was if we'd had,
if it was a full of Parabola,
then we know it would have been at the ground before I set my clock to zeroes.
First of all,
negative time should not bother anybody.
T equals zero is when I set the clock a measured time forward.
But yesterday would be t equal to minus one day.
Right?
So we don't have any trouble with negative times.
So the point is this equation,
that's not,
no,
I bought the building,
doesn't know the whole song and dance that you went to a building and he threw
up a rocket,
knows nothing.
What does the mathematics,
no,
it knows that this particle happened to have a height of 15 at time zero and a
velocity of 10 at times zero and it is falling under gravity with an
acceleration of minus 10 that's all it knows.
If that solid noise then in that scenario,
if that is no building at anything else,
it continues a trajectory both forward and time and backward in time.
And it says that um,
whatever seconds,
one second before you set your clock to zero,
it would have been in the ground.
What it means is if you release the rock at that location one second before with
a certain speed that we can calculate,
it would have ended up here with precisely the position and velocity had had at
the beginning of I would expect.
So sometimes the extra solution is very interesting and you should always listen
to the mathematics when you get extra solutions.
In fact,
when a very famous physicist called Dirac was looking for the energy of a
particle in relativistic quantum mechanics,
he found the energy of a product is connected.
There's momentum.
This P is what we call momentum and it's mass.
Bye.
This is relation.
It's a particular mass m and momentum p has this energy.
So you saw it for the energy,
you get two answers.
Okay?
Oh,
your temptation is to keep the first answer because you know energy is not going
to be negative particles moving.
It's got some energy and that's it.
But the mathematicians stall Dereck,
you cannot ignore the negative energy solution because it tells you there's a
second solution and you cannot throw them out and it turns out the second
solution with negative energy was when the theory is telling you,
hey,
that are particles in their antibiotics and the negative energy you've been
properly interpreted.
We'll describe antibiotics.
So the equations are very smart.
The way the physics works is you find some loss of motion in mathematical form.
You put it in the initial conditions or whatever.
You solve the equations and the answer that comes,
you have no choice.
You have to accept the answer.
Is that our new answers besides the one you were looking for,
you got to think about what they mean and that's one of the best things of what
physics because he us a person was not looking for antibiotics.
You guys trying to describe,
I like France,
but the theory said there are two routes in the quadratic equation and the
second route is mathematically as interesting as the first one.
It has to be part of the theory and then trying to adjust it so it can be
incorporated.
You discovered antibiotics.
So always amazing to us how we go into the problem.
I would,
I,
our mind can see one class of solutions,
but the math will tell you sometimes there are new solutions and you got
respected and understand and interpret the unwanted solutions.
And this is a simple example where you can follow what the meaning of the second
solution.
Yes.
It means that to the problem you post that is more than the answers that you
could imagine.
He hit it meant article that was released from the ground earlier that it meant
something much more interesting.
Namely antiparticles accompanying particles.
They are going to accompany particle.
Surely as it is quadratic equation is two solutions.
All right,
so now in this problem they can do something slightly different and that's used
this expression here and I will do that.
Then I'll stop for today.
If you were asking questions like how high does it go,
but you don't ask,
when does it go to the highest point?
Then you don't have to go through the whole process of finding the time at which
it turned around.
I don't know where that is that disappear in the blackboard.
Then putting the time equal to one second into this formula.
If the question of time is not explicitly brought up,
then you should know that you have to use this formula.
So how do we get it here?
Well,
we say at the top of the loop when it goes up and comes down,
the velocity is zero.
Therefore you say zero square
equals initial velocity squared plus two flames minus G.
That's my acceleration times.
Y minus Y is zero.
If you solve for that,
you find y minus y Zero Equals v Zero Square over to g and if you put in The v
Zero I gave you which was what a pen,
there's hundred over 20 which is five meters,
so y equals y is zero plus five meters and that is the height to weight that
rises.
I think we got it somewhere else.
We phoned the maximum height to be 20 meters.
Another thing you can do is you can find the speed.
If you want to find the speed there,
you put the Equation v Square Equals v Zero Square plus two times minus g.
What does y minus y zero the final why is zero the initial y is minus is 15 you
solve for that equation.
Then you will find the final velocity.
So if time is not involved you can do it that way.
I wanted did I the last result in another way,
then I will stop and that's pretty interesting because it tells you a use and
abuse of calculus.
I'm going to find for you this result using calculus in a different way.
So from the calculus we know DVD t is equal to a
multiply both sides by V.
Okay.
No,
you have to know from Elementary Calculus that v Times Dvdt is really d by Dt of
the square over two.
No,
I hope you guys know that much calculus that when you take a derivative of the
function of a function,
namely v squared over two is a function of v And v itself as a function of tea
than the rule for taking the derivative is first take the v Derivative,
this object.
Then take the d by Dt of the,
which is this one,
the right hand side.
I'm going to write us a Dxdt.
Yeah,
this much as standard,
but no.
Here's what I'm,
yeah,
I'm going to do something with somehow we are told never ever to do,
which is to just cancel the
dts.
You all know that when you do the white Dx,
you're not supposed to cancel that d that's actually correct.
Okay.
You don't want to cancel the d and the date of it too,
but this happens to be completely legitimate so I'm going to assume it's true
and I'll maybe take a second to explain why he's related to me.
What this really means is in a given time,
Delta t the change in this quantity is eight time.
The change in this quantity that for you can multiply both sides by the Delta t
but the only thing you should understand this delta t as long as they're small
and finite will lead to some small and finite editors in the formula because the
formula is really the limit in with Delta x and Delta t both go to zero.
So what do you have to do is multiply both sides by Delta t but remember it's
got to be in the end made vanishingly small.
As long as we understand that we can do this cancellation.
And this says on the left hand side,
the change in the Quantity v squared over two is the change a time.
The change in the quantity x.
So add up all the changes are,
what do you mean by integral?
Same thing.
Add up all the changes.
The change in v squared over two will be the final v squared over two minus the
initial v squared over to the other side will be eight times the change in x.
X minus x not.
Yeah,
and that's the formula I wrote for you.
This wade is Vz to squared plus two x minus X.
Now,
so the point is whenever you have directives with something over Dt,
do not hesitate to cancel the dts and think of them as a Delta v squared over
two is equal to eight times delta x.
This will be actually true as long as both quantities are vanishingly small,
they will become more and more true.
As delta x and Delta p squared become vanishingly small in the limit and we're
still approaching zero,
the two will be in fact equal.
You've dealt by acts as a finite.
I'm only like one second.
This will not be true because in the starting equation,
Delta x and Delta t and Delta v Square or all assumed to be infinitesimal.
Yeah,
so don't hesitate to do manipulations of this type and I will do them quite
often.
So you got to understand when it's okay and when it's not.
Okay.
Yeah.
What this means is in a time Delta t this wanted to changes by some amount and
the same time Delta t that wanted changes by some amount than keeping the delta
t equal to some number.
We may equate the changes in the two quantities provided it is understood.
The Delta v Square over two is a change in v squared over two in the same time
in which the particle moved a distance delta x.
Then by adding the differences we eliminate time and we get this final result.
All right,
so if you go onto your website today,
you will find I have assigned some problems and you should try to do them.
They applied to this chapter.
Then next week we'll do more complicated problems that involve motion and higher
dimension.
How to go to two dimensions of vitamins.